Cô kêu chào lên bằng Mỹ, M.I.N.H.M.S.N. Tùng báo, tại nhiều chào vụ phát hiện cô cả yên tại nhà chẳng năm 2020.
Đông thời khởi đồng lại 2 của 1 tình, người chân cả trong những kỳ ông Biden, gồm Bóg Zorzý, giữ Thao và Nguet, Tỏan, Tối Cào, về quyền Phá Thay, năm 2020.
Và Bóg đặc bong ông ngữ Washington năm 2020.
Vết trên chẳng mạng sau hội ấy cả nhân, phó giống lúc M.I.N.Bong Gino, người đường ông Trump bộ nghiệm cho biết,
vụ cô cả yên sẽ được tù tiền tập viện khi được vô xúc nhân lực và yêu cầu báo gạo tình đô hàng tần.
Trước đó, người thẳng bây, năm 2020, mật vụ Mỹ phát hiện một gọi chất một mổ chẳng được xất định là cô cả yên,
gần lối gạo cảnh tay nhà chẳng, cô đều chào khi đó, kết thúc mạng không xa định được người xảy hữu.
Vụ việc gần chùi lớn khi ông Trump lúc đó là ở viên tầm thống gạo vụ chất này hóa thủ về ai ngoài ở Biden, hoặc còn trái.
Cứ tổng thống Joe Biden bôn có hai nghỉ còn trái,
người còn trái cả bông Biden đã mất bị ông thủ nả ông năm 2019.
Gửa còn trái thủ hành tơ của ông bôn có tên xử nghiệm mặt tuy ý và tình bị trí tổ hình xử bị kai mang mô xủng khi đang trong quá trình kai nhận.
Chứ khi rồi nhớ, ông Joe Biden đã xử dụng quyền lực thống thống để ăn xả trong người còn trái mình.
Ông Joe Biden mới đây cũng được trình đoàn mắt ông thư Tên lịch, chuyển át tính và đã dí cân.